[Music]
guys
what's going on today we're having a
drone day we're
actually out here at willow race
springs willow something i don't know
it's a racetrack
it's far away through about an hour and
a half to get here that's basically how
far
out of los angeles you have to go to be
able to freely kind of fly some drones
but we're here with some professional
drone pilots
and uh they're gonna show me how much
better they are than flying to me
this is like my drone dreams come true
this is
this is what we need i've been doing
everything all wrong gear truck
for the platform filming on the a1 right
now the a7 s3 and
sony let us borrow this 200 to 600
millimeter lens and we're gonna see if
we can try to follow and track the
drones as we're flying
oh this is gonna be great ten thousand
dollars a drone
it's always super relaxing to fly i'm
stressed for you guys
what could go wrong honestly oh gosh
please don't say that
it's only my camera so my name is jake
i'm from drone dudes we're an aerial
cinematography company
out of los angeles we specialize in any
kind of remote cinematography so mostly
drones today we're going to be flying a
couple of different drones we've got the
money shot mini which paul
nerc is going to be flying he's a drl
world champion so he's going to give
that thing a proper workout that's the
latest and greatest kind of heavy lift
cinema fpv drone it's carrying the red
komodo which is like the tiny
pocket-sized red camera and he's going
to be chasing around behind the
motorcycles and then we're going to flip
over to the inspire 2 which is like a
more traditional cinema drone and even
justine i think is going to get in on
the sticks on that
so do you think that you're going to
trust me hopping that camera oh
definitely
you've worked with a lot of cameras in a
lot of tech this is no different i fly a
lot of drones just not
fpv full manual not ready for that yet
or maybe i am we'll get there yeah
paul's the one to train you up so we're
out here at willow springs raceway
uh drone dudes uh invited me out to come
and fly their money shot mini
which is a drum that carries the red
komodo and we were chasing a couple
awesome motorcycles across the track and
we figured if you wanted to come and
hang out you might as well come
buy some drones check out some cool
bikes for anybody that doesn't know like
do you want to give a brief history of
like your fpv
roll flying background because
incredibly
talented pilot yeah so i started flying
drones in 2014 my in-laws bought me like
a toy drone for christmas one year
and i broke it immediately i'm like i'm
kind of an engineer i was a programmer
at the time i was like i should be able
to figure out how to fix this so
searched around got a youtube university
education in fixing drones
and along the way discovered drone
racing i
just like as soon as i saw it i was like
i have to try that it is the coolest
thing in the world
and that took me around the world i got
to go like all across the united states
china germany united kingdom and
eventually became the 2018 world
champion
of drone racing yeah so it's uh it was
it was an awesome year and i'm
so proud to have that title because it
gives me opportunity
to come out and tell more stories about
drones and drone racing and what it can
do
it's so cool well thanks for the invite
this is like the coolest thing ever
i was like tyler we're gonna go fly
drones with cool people let's go
[Music]
then
that was uh pretty freaking cool
time
i'll give you the tutorial and if you
want to film that or whatever yeah
however you want to get it
nice i have my hat on i'm ready are we
ready
let's do it this is called the sentence
remote from dji it's kind of their like
big
fancy inspire remote
i feel pretty good i mean i'm not
piloting i'm just basically camera ops
so
like what could go
[Music]
that's perfect you got them you got them
hold it
oh yeah
[Music]
legit though anytime that you want to
work with us
you did great
so much fun i just i love i mean i
wasn't actually flying but like the
whole
everything that goes into flyington's
i'm just i just love it it's just like
such an exhilarating feeling and it's so
fun just
freeing it was actually great because
not having to worry about flying and
just focusing on kind of
using the camera and piloting that part
is really cool
and i think i just got a job offer so
i'm pretty excited
i wonder when i start so should i do i
start monday
monday yeah so i think you know okay
monday is good for us
it's good for you um let me check my
schedule
i'm free i mean we have four shoots next
week so the sooner you can start the
better great
dude that's it this was so much fun i
love drones i love flying them i love
watching people fly them
and obviously being here with like the
best of the best
is so inspiring i'll put links in the
description if you guys want to check
out all things drone dudes and be sure
to check out newark's youtube channel
because he does
so much incredible content with drones
go check it out i'll see you guys later
thanks for watching see you the next one
[Music]
cheers
so
[Music]
you